la vidéo de barrichello
rappelle-moi pas seulement tpg le regard
tout triste depuis que mon bar aux eti
par qu'il a à mon avis qui a tué la page
bonne question tout le monde me le
demande dans la mesure de savoir quand
même ça pour être sichuan je dirais les
toits des balances poteau c'est mon rêve
de sky celui qui a tiré sur apache ccrg
m'embrouiller retour et j'ai eu une
petite faiblesse pour combien on va
parler un peu tout et mon jardin je
pense
bête était peut-être masters ce game sur
l'oubli sinon c'est franck gastambide si
le café la série je sais qu est ce que
je te dise moi je sais que je peux pas
vous le dire
[Musique]